в'їзд би зірку хвилі та грузини душі
нижче 90 днів проти Європи
підлагоджуватися душін гени b2 зможе вище
владно до біометричних паспортів
сагалова наумова на тему паспорті замість
Тема формату править побут копати і владно
до cd і зможуть рекорду на кому виправили
ти че люди на
на вітрильник крем того при кордону до
можете допомагати дадуть кого pv не
документи а по парі вірить і ми тупо
дружимо запитані відро дачі вч і
друзів легше ви бачили дають і близьких
бронювання готелів спільного по дружу це
я турист запрошений або ділових партнерів
взуття дозатори конференцій та загалом це
без цієї бізнес запрошення завершити етап
і підтвердження прочешу семінарах я все
вийде і
початкову миту а крим то ви можете у
магате
заворотна квітка підтвердження
фінансово з потужності в розробку
близько 40 євро треба б перебування
м'язову страховку
без цих може бути скільки за вступним у
team злитий за методом і безвізовий режим на
не дає права грузинам на роботу
також треба їй підстав для виїзду на
пластини проживання в цих двох випусках
грузинам та долини активно будуть
спеціально візам таких провалів пісня
початку diy безвізового режиму будуть ще
до громадян України